now the question you're asking is
brother ali what on earth
are you doing in front of a billboard
and if you read a book
called beauty sick you will understand
that this has a ripple effect the point
is this the reason i'm doing this video
is because we need to put an end to this
i have to perform to this and have to
act
and there you go
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below
you can also use the discount code
salaam 10
for 10 of their products assalamu
alaikum atmosphere
two brothers and sisters dear friend now
the question you're asking is brother
ali
what on earth are you doing in front of
a billboard near the a406
embarking next to a police station that
police officer came
and said what are you doing here thank
god he was a muslim um and yeah we just
said you know don't worry tell the
police obviously subscribe to my channel
now the reason i came today brother and
sisters is in in a minute you're going
to be seeing
a banner right on top of here let me
just get this side don't get
uh run over there you go the guys give
the thumbs up so the thumbs up means
we're good to go okay that obviously
they've been stunk a bit
uh the rubbish bin what you just saw
behind me obviously while i was doing
that guys
is a woman now this woman has a red
chili in her mouth
she's a blonde woman dressed up i would
say inappropriately
and she says something really
interesting so in a minute it's going to
pop back up roman sisters
the reason i'm doing this video is
because and the reason i came out here
because i believe it's really important
yeah so much so
i had my issues i had to use my wife's
uh phone
as a mic in today's time bro and sisters
women have become so sexualized and this
ad is from them we pay more for scrap
metal yeah so bear in mind
this is an ad from them yeah it's metal
it's metal i really want to know the
question what on earth
does a metal company that scrap metal
have to do with a blonde woman who's
dressed in a
provocative way and it's got a red
chilli in her mouth and there's a slogan
there
now this ties in very closely i believe
where people are turning a blind eye to
this whole kidnapping of
sarah yeah a young woman walking home
alone gets kidnapped by a police officer
it doesn't matter
whoever he was here he gets cleaned up
by a police officer and
is raped and beaten and killed
and her body was chalked about 90 or 100
kilometers away
in kent so in a minute we're going to
see the banner here we go guys
this is there we go the hottest scrap
metal prizes
in town and there's a woman there
dressed up in an appropriate way
obviously i had to look to read the
writing
and she's got hot chili in her mouth and
she's biting into the hot chili
in a seductive way now if we treat women
like this how do you expect men to value
and humanize them
they have been dehumanized now nazi
germany in nuremberg
the people before hitler
asked the people to execute the jewish
people they couldn't do that they had to
be dehumanized to a certain level
and that is exactly what was done he
dehumanized the jews to such a level
with
propaganda banners or whatever it may be
that when it came to the point where the
trigger had to be pulled
the people justified it to their self
now how does this connect
to this woman for scrap metal they go
for them having a hot chili
the point is this woman are sexualized
to such a point that recent studies
showed that these women who are hired to
do modeling
they prefer to be sexually objectified
to
items that are expensive so i'm sure
most likely of that study shows that
this woman
on there would most likely will be not
happy being on this
uh advertising boy because it's about
metal scrap metal
i mean how low can you use a woman for a
scrap metal okay that was one of the
study shows yeah the woman's preferred
to
be sexually objectified for expensive
stuff like rolex or gucci or rolls-royce
and stuff like that yeah
however brothers and sisters and this is
a reminder to
everybody when we dehumanize women and
make them seem as nothing but sexual
objects
that they have to dress in mini skirts
show their cleavage
act a certain way put lipstick on get
their lips filled
get their bum their backside bigger get
their hips done get their boobs done
all we've done is we've made a human
being a
female human being seem as if the only
thing she has to offer is her sexual
body
is her is her sexuality and her body
parts right
we know that the pornography industry
has already dehumanized them to such a
level
that even in these movies you see them
they are the ones at the receiving end
yeah being slapped around and all kind
of disgusting things
the point is this the reason i'm doing
this video is because we need to put an
end to this
if we don't do not be surprised if you
have men who are cat-calling women
yeah because allah tells us in the quran
tell the believing men to lower their
gates
so god almighty is telling men how to
behave we are not told
that women have to cover up because men
can't control themselves
no that might be a wisdom behind it
maybe
but that is not the reason we are told
we have to lower our gaze regardless as
a muslim man
even if a woman is dressed up naked in a
mini skirt
i have to lower my gaze and avoid it
that is the reason why when i confronted
certain people at the far right they
were so keen on shaking my hand they
just wanted to have some kind of
interaction with me
in islam we believe prevention is better
than cure that's the reason why i don't
shake the hands of the opposite gender i
do not have
friends with opposite gender because i
know how god has created me it's not
that i can't control myself
it's because at the end of the day there
are desires between
men and women that's why this even i did
a social experiment showing that men and
women can't just be friends and their
studies show this they can't be
but my point today with this video with
this red hot chili in her mouth
is that we are sexualizing women and
we're doing this systematically
so much so that men do not see women as
human beings not as co-human beings as
co-individuals that have more to offer
than their damn sexual body parts right
and i want to end on that
and look at this it's unbelievable guys
if it comes again you're going to see
for yourself
but it's absolutely shocking and it's
disgusting
and the more we don't put a stop to this
more people are going to get raped
more women are going to be treated like
crap and all they're going to be do
all they're going to be seeing useful
for is
sexual gratification and if you read a
book called beauty sick you will
understand that this has a ripple effect
when you make women feel as if
that they have to beautify themselves
and the industry the makeup industry the
beauty industry makes them feel
ugly and ugly uh do you have woman in
that book read the book beauty secret i
encourage every single woman to read it
yeah you see that there are girls
starving their self to look a certain
way some of them they are so affected by
this their mental
health is being affected because they
are not the perfect body that seems
that is is they're going yeah today
today's fashion you know
it's sad and our daughters are uh
i have to perform to this and have to
act
and there you go the hottest scrap metal
prizes in town and you can see very
clearly brothers and sisters
that uh thank you my uh wife beep to let
me know that he came up here so you saw
there that brothers and sisters
that if we carry this on men are going
to treat women
the same damn way we need to honor women
we need to respect women
we need to treat them as a creation of
god that needs to be honored that's
why islam has let so many rights for
women
that if i want to marry my wife i had to
go i didn't take her out for dates i
didn't say let's go and
do abcd whatever let me you know test
drive before i buy
no i had to speak to her father her
guardian to show that i'm
real and i'm genuine she has a right to
math she has a right
for me to ask if she would like to marry
me can't be forced marriages
so the thing is islam is honored woman
and the reason why women dress up in
a muslim dress up in a way that doesn't
show their body parts
is because they do not want to be judged
based on what they can offer
there but rather what they can offer as
a human being here
and i hope that sends a good message out
there and i hope
that we can humanize women again and
protect them from being dehumanized with
these sexual banners and posters
that was it brothers and sisters hope
you guys have benefited until next time
assalamu alaikum say better to hope you
benefited from this video you can share
this with your friends and family until
next time
goodbye